le led la com qu en charge à 100 devant
ni derrière toujours habillé comme l'as
de pique ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une
vraie performance d'artiste nathaly
coualy incarne quatre personnages à la
fois un exercice extraordinaire qui en
plus des multiples jeux de scène
sollicite la mémoire de la comédienne
c'est une sordide histoire qu'elle nous
raconte tout est noir tout est tragique
tout est si difficile à encaisser et
intégrée parfois des tranches de vie
sorti tout droit du roman désirade à de
maryse condé adapté pour le théâtre par
l'auteure elle-même à cause des fripes
ans peu importe qu'elle m'aurait donné
ce qui me plaisait aussi c'est
l'exercice de me2 de servir ses mots et
de voie de le faire quoi si on fait
passation prend pas des risques dans ce
métier là enfin des femmes dans la vie
tout simplement
la musique qui accompagne chaque état
d'âme de la comédienne est créée par
rigaud drane et les instruments les
sonorités et les rythmes 1 tout est
calculé
on est dans la culture
[Musique]
c'est en fonction du contenu de
l'émotion qui a dans cette pièce
lorsqu'elle est chargée d'émotion de
monte à l'autre et c'est ce qui a fait
que voilà j'ai travaillé une musique qui
pouvait s'insérer et accompagner cette
émotion une pièce mise en scène par
antoine hervé il découvre alors un récit
poignant qui a pris naissance en
guadeloupe mais qui selon lui aurait pu
émaner de n'importe quelle région du
monde
c'est un truc que je j'estime
complètement universelle en fait c'est
ça qui m'intéresse
on est on est vraiment dans une histoire
de femmes au pluriel
ce que j'adore c'est que cette femme là
marie noëlle convoi et sa mère et sa
grand mère c'est la même j'adore ces
moments de transition où par exemple
elle est à moitié nina à moitié marie
noëlle et elle dit je cherchais sont
dans son visage les traits qui ressemble
au mien
et c'est donc on est on est dans quelque
chose de complètement universel entendu
dans l'opulence en souffrent daisy radar
ferme le festival des petites formes
demain soir
[Applaudissements]